-We must still
unthrone her, my point.
The great love story aside.
-She may sit on your face,
but not on your throne.
It was a joke!
-You will see a lot
of different characters
who you didn't see
interact together on season one.
-We've got a great
ensemble of actors
who bring so much
to the table.
-Huzzah.
-Huzzah!
-You get to see the characters
that you enjoyed
in the first season...
developing in really fun ways.
-This is great!
-We're his new best friends.
-Exactly! I can be everything
Grigor was to him.
-What is it, bitch?
-Marial is Catherine's
cynical voice of reason.
I'm quite honest with her.
-You betrayed me.
-Saved.
-Betrayed.
-Are you alive?
-Catherine still kind of holds
that over her a bit.
-Would you like some, Marial?
-So you do remember my name.
-Of course.
-ELLE: Marial and Grigor
had this fantastic relationship
in season two.
And that's very exciting.
-What are you doing?
-Changing the world.
PHOEBE: Marial and Catherine
are both hungry for power
and we are using each other.
-She is stubborn, yes,
but she is also brilliant.
-I hold out my hand
in friendship.
I do not want to close it
into a fist.
-Archie gets visions from God
by taking magic mushrooms
in the woods.
-Did you see him?
-I saw a shining light.
-They didn't have
such a great start.
-He's the traditionalist
who wants to keep things
exactly the way they are.
So that puts him
in opposition to Catherine.
-You are a German devil
who has stolen our country
and is intent on burning Russia
to the ground.
-Archie, be on the right side.
-Georgina really
admires Catherine.
-I once felt a strong
connection with you.
-We've had sex,
which I did not enjoy much.
-She is in this
really unusual relationship
with both Peter
and her husband Grigor.
-You summoned me?
-It's an interesting
little love triangle, I suppose.
Grigor is Peter's
best friend and confidant.
-You need to shut up.
-I'm worried
his love for Catherine
is a brake on our plans.
-I do not love her.
-Huzzah!
-Grigor is probably one of
the few people in the court
who Peter can really be himself
and show his weakness.
-Seems a bit strong.
She came to me unbidden.
-You must make her believe
there is more to you
than there is.
-Elizabeth is really
interesting because on one hand,
she's a bit
of a political player.
But she's also
a bit of a bohemian.
-You put a crown on a donkey,
it is still a donkey.
-She realizes that Catherine,
I think, has amazing attributes
that would make her
a brilliant leader.
-The joy of being a woman
is knowing that we have unseen
and unacknowledged depths
and strengths
beyond anything
a man will ever know.
-Oh, right. Of course. Sorry.
-Velementov is still very
old-fashioned in my thoughts
about whether a woman, and a
young woman, can actually lead.
-I shall ready battle plans.
-What is wrong with you?
-A general readies war plans,
it's sort of the job.
-There's a sort of journey
to go on with her
where I gradually
believe in her.
-It's a war order.
I take it personally.
-She dies.
He comes back.
-Catherine
and Orlo together,
they'll bring the best
out of one another,
making Russia great again.
-In one moment,
58 million people are freed.
-Steps.
A mile is made in steps.
-I teach Catherine how to play
the game here at the palace.
-Head, not heart, Catherine.
-Reason, not rage, Orlo.
-And Catherine teaches Orlo
to live dangerously.
Be fearless
and take some big risks.
-I had sex last night
with a woman.
-Cute.
-I like that you're fitting
all these different characters
together that
might not quite fit.
I think from that comes
really exciting ideas.
Huzzah.